everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve sum of two integers and finally
this is actually the last blind 75
question that we have to do on this
channel we've been tracking all the
blind 75 problems on the spreadsheet
link will be in the description if you
want to take a look i've actually
finished all the questions even a couple
of them that are blank i've recorded
those and this sum of two integers is
finally the last blind 75 question we
have remaining okay now let's get into
the problem so we're given two integers
a and b and we want to return the sum of
these two integers and the only catch is
that we have to do this without using
the plus and minus operators and that's
definitely going to make this tricky and
by the way don't uh pay attention to
this dislike up above so i'm sure you
know how addition works we have one plus
two and the output is going to be three
so if we can't use plus and minus we
have to get creative and by creative we
mean bit manipulation so when we look at
the integer 1 it's going to look like
this in binary representation the
integer 2 is going to look like this so
we know of course if we add these right
we can do it digit by digit this is
going to be 1 this is also going to be 1
and this is the binary representation
for 3. so that works but of course we
have to do it without doing the plus
operation so we're gonna have to do some
kind of bit manipulation operation on
each of these bits so let's think about
this if we had a one and we had a zero
we know that adding these two together
is gonna give us a one in the output but
we can't use addition what kind of
operation logical operation could we do
on these two bits to figure out that the
answer is one we know that this could be
a zero and this could be a one or this
could be a zero and this could be a one
and adding these together still would be
a one in the output so if one of these
digits is a one we will have a one in
the output but what would happen if both
of these digits were a one then we'd
have a zero in the output and we'd have
a one that's a carry value that we're
gonna you know shift left and then add
that carry to the remaining digits and
by the way we could also have two
zeros and of course zero added together
would be zero so what we really
discovered is that if one of these is a
one digit only one of these is a one
digit then we'll have a one in the
output but if they're both ones then
we'll have a zero in the output and if
they're both zeros then we'll also have
a zero in the output so what we have
discovered is actually a logical
operator called xor or exclusive or it
basically means only one of these two
digits is one then you'll have a one in
the output if both of the digits are the
same then we'll have a zero in the
output and that's exactly what we need
in this problem so xor works if we have
two ones here though and we do the xor
operation we're gonna get a zero
in the output digit which is exactly
what we want but we also want a one
carry how do we get that one carry well
you first have to ask yourself in what
case are we going to have a carry digit
right when are we going to have this
carry well if we have two zeros we're
definitely not going to have a carry if
we have a single zero then we're also
not going to have a carry but if we have
two ones this is the only case that
we're going to have a carry so how do we
know if we have two ones well we can use
another logic operator called the and
operator so if a and b are one then we
know we'll have a one carry but that one
carry is not going to be added over here
that one carry is gonna be in
the left spot it's gonna be shifted to
the left by one so actually when we do
this a and b operation we want to take
it and then shift it to the left by one
and then take this or this new integer
that we've discovered right and then
take that and then add it here so we're
actually gonna have a loop we're gonna
do an xor operation and then if we have
a carry value we're going to actually
take that new carry value and then add
it again to whatever we have left
remaining now let's try this idea that i
just talked about on one of these
examples and what we're going to figure
out is actually when we're doing these
logic operators we don't have to do them
one by one we can do them on the
entirety of a and b that we're given
okay so now let's take a look at an
example we want to add a which is the
integer 9 in binary representation it
looks like this and we want to add b
which is 11 and this is what it looks
like in binary representation well we
want to add them but we know we can't
use plus and minus so
what we're gonna do is run the exclusive
or operation which in code i think it
looks like this we want to run the
exclusive or on these bit by bit and we
can do it on the entire integer a and b
if we exclusive or them together uh
first this bit well they're both one so
that's going to be a zero in this case
one of them is a one so we're going to
have a one in the output in this case
they're both zero we have a zero in the
output in this case they're both one we
have a zero in the output but what
integer is this this is just the integer
two but obviously nine plus eleven is
not two so we missed something basically
we didn't do the and right in this case
we're going to have a carry one that's
going to be over here right and we're
also going to have a carry from these
two which is going to be over here so
what we want to do is take this new
integer which is going to look like this
and then add that with the result of a
xor b
the xor does add these numbers it just
doesn't take care of the carry so we
have to take care of the carry ourselves
and uh when we
basically take a logic and with b we
also want to shift it to the left by one
and then we'll get some other integer so
by the way over here we're going to take
a and b and then shift it to the left by
one so
when we end these two together we get a
one when we and these two together we
get a zero when we and these two we get
a zero when we and these two we get a
one but we remember we want to take this
and shift it to the left by one so what
we're actually gonna have is a one here
zero zero one right and then this will
just this uh place will just get filled
with a zero so now we wanna take these
two numbers and add them together and
when we say add them together we're
going to do the same exact operations we
did here so we're going to first xor
these exclusive wearing these we get a
zero exclusive wearing these we get a
zero exclusive or these we get zero
again zero here though we do get a one
so we got the exclusive or now we want
to get the and of them shifted to the
left by one so and these two nothing and
these two we get a one and of course we
want to shift it to the left by one
which means we'll have a one over here
so i'll just put that one over here
because we know for the rest of these uh
this is not going to be ended and this
is not going to be ended so
this will basically be zero zero
everything is zero except this so now we
want to add these two together again
we're going to do our xor operation
first xoring these these nothing here we
get a 1
nothing here here we get a 1 and
when you and these two together we just
get a zero in the output right logic
ending these two will get us a zero
which basically means we don't have a
carry in this case which means we are
finished adding them together right if
we don't have a carry that means we're
done so this is the result in that case
now what number is this well it's 16
plus 4 which is 20 which is exactly what
we were looking for right because we
were adding 9 plus 11. so i hope that
this makes sense and i hope you kind of
understand why it works so now we can
get into the code and actually what is
going to be the time complexity of this
solution well it's going to be constant
time because first we're we're told that
the integers a and b are going to be
between negative 1000 and positive 1000
and how many times could we actually do
this loop uh you know before getting a
carry that's you know zero
it can't go run forever like of course
if these were arbitrarily large integers
then in that case
we might have like a linear time
algorithm but for the most part this is
constant time and one more thing i want
to mention is how are we going to handle
negative numbers well negative numbers
will actually handle themselves and i
don't want to go too in detail to that
we could talk about like two's
complement and stuff like that but what
you need to know is this operation um
xoring and ending them this is
equivalent to addition and we know that
in most languages if you take negative
three you know plus positive number this
will give us the correct output which is
positive one in this case and since this
is basically equivalent to addition as
long as the language we're using handles
binary representation correctly it
should work for us one thing i want to
mention is i'm actually going to code
this up in java today not python because
python integers are arbitrarily large
they're not 32-bit so it kind of runs
into problems with this algorithm and
just to keep it simple i'm just going to
use java okay so now let's code it up
and yes uh believe it or not i do know
java i have coded java even though i use
python pretty much exclusively on this
channel so now let's do our loop and
remember the condition we're doing our
loop is basically until the carry value
ends up being 0 and b is what we're
going to use for the carry in this case
and you'll see what i mean in a second
so what we want to do is we want to
assign a equal to a x or b just like we
kind of did in the drawing explanation
and we want to set b
equal to a anded with b and then bit
shifted to the left by one and then we
want to go to the next iteration of the
loop basically doing the same thing and
we learned that these two operations are
equivalent to adding a and b together
but one little catch is that if we
already assign a to the exclusive or
then when we try to assign b we're using
the new value of a when we actually want
to use the old value of a
so before we
reassign a i'm just going to actually
calculate a temporary integer which is
basically our and condition which is
going to be a and b
shifted to the left by one and then
instead i'm going to assign b equal to
that temporary value to make sure that
we use the original value of a not the
new value of a and once we're done with
that eventually b will equal 0 b is the
carry and then we can go ahead and
return the result which is going to be
stored in a okay now let's run it to
make sure that it works and on the left
you can see that yes it works and it is
pretty efficient so i really hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it really supports the
channel a lot consider checking out my
patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching